news from Lucas film Dave filon has been
promoted to Chief creative officer he's
answering directly to Kathleen Kennedy
and he's basically taking control of the
creative decisions that's probably a
good idea they really should have
somebody in that position I don't know
if they technically did before it
certainly doesn't seem like it and the
news that I'm seeing doesn't mention him
replacing anybody but if they're going
to put somebody in that position to
oversee things creatively he's probably
a good pick he's had his hand in Star
Wars for a while I mean pretty much all
the streaming stuff he's touched at
least and even before that with things
like clone Wars and Rebels and whatnot
and pretty much all the streaming stuff
that's been going has either been
created co-created by Him or he's
written for it or he's directed for it
so he's he's all over this thing already
it's a natural pick for me this doesn't
mean a whole lot I have to be honest his
contributions to Star Wars seem fine
don't get me wrong but I haven't really
connected with them and so I don't I
don't get excited by his involvement
though if you like his stuff I'm sure
this is great news and probably a good
idea overall